hey everyone it's Mike from overflows
and welcome to this latest video on go
charting uh with order flows Trader on
there so you know yesterday I made that
video for you explaining uh that we have
now the order flows Trader on the go
charting platform which is a web-based
platform so
um you know I know a lot of people in
the past have wanted to use the
overflows Trader on a Mac and
ninjatrader doesn't run on a Mac it runs
on a PC but since the go charting
platform
is web-based you know you could use it
on a Mac I use it on you know a desktop
I also use it on my Samsung fold phone
so
you know you could use doesn't matter
what as long as you are you know able to
basically get to the internet you can
use the go charting uh platform so again
you know right now I have a special deal
with the guys that go charting so for
the month of September you know you can
subscribe to the data at a reduced rate
of only ten dollars a month as opposed
to the normal rate of 35 that gets you
real-time data for the CME is this the
the CME the main products like uh
e-minis uh mes NQ mnq the currencies you
know some of the Lesser contracts like
you know even though CME does trade Hogs
and cattle it's not available
um
as far as the footprint chart goes on go
charting so again go to uh the link
below is in the description if you go to
the normal gold charting website
um you can but you're going to be
charged the full rate for the data which
is 35 otherwise you know you're going to
be able to get it for the the reduced
price of ten dollars for the month and
the order flows Trader until September
1st I believe is free so if you want to
try it out get used to it you know by
all means you know you want to take
advantage of this special offer so you
know once you're on the main go charting
page you're going to go to go chart go
to the charts under products or you
could click up here to charts it doesn't
really matter and it's going to take you
to the Chart right you see how fast it
loads so this is the uh the Nifty the
default I have set up is Nifty but if
you want to see the es right the mes or
NQ you just type it in up here right
this area up in here you just type in
the symbol right we know for e-minis
it's es you and then you can see down
here you get the menu just expand it up
find the the current month and here is
your charge okay now again if you're
familiar with say ninjatrader or share
charts coming to a new trading platform
is different right we get so used to
using a certain trading platform that we
expect that when we go to another
platform everything is the same but
unfortunately it's not like that now the
guys
at go charting they are
you know they're they're a great team of
guys and you know what they've built is
a very robust package it just does there
is unfortunately there is a learning
curve I mean with any new software
whether it's trading software or
whatever there is going to be a learning
curve all right so
what you want to do first is you're
going to want to add the footprint right
the basic footprint which comes with go
charting so you don't have to pay extra
you know like if you get the the
we want the cluster chart oh well we're
going to call it on ninjatrader
volumetric
um you'd have to you got to pay an extra
you gotta buy a lifetime license
basically which is you know I don't know
what it goes for now about 11 1200 but
on go charting it's included in your
subscription so they call it the cluster
so you're going to hit uh you're going
to go here where it says uh charts and
down at the bottom is cluster okay and
you're gonna see it here you're gonna
say oh it's still bar charts well what
you have to do is you have to expand it
okay and there you go you can start to
see
the footprints okay now people ask how
do I get your indicators on here well
the next step is you have to go to study
okay you're going to click on study go
order flow and expand the menu out you
can see Market profile volume profile V
web Etc then find order flows Trader
click on that okay now you're gonna
start to see some things on your chart
so the The Next Step that you want to do
is you're going to go over to on the
right hand side at the top there's like
these three there's a square
and then like three or four layers
because it's the layers basically what
what is sitting on your charge so you
can see here this pops up this menu okay
so you see I got the cluster right and
you click on the word cluster it's going
to open this up and you're gonna have
all these
functions in here that you can use okay
say you want to have the value areas
right on your chart
or you know the previous point of
control marker right you'd click it like
this you know all these things you on
off basically to
to show it okay
now you see people say well like the
value areas I can't see the value areas
I've got it clicked that's because you
got to change the color okay so
um yeah you're going to change the color
to what I don't know gray then you could
adjust the opacity so you have the
colors on top and these have just this
line right below which is sort of the
opacity so you could color it whatever
you like you know hover dark or not I
like to be able to read
excuse me you know sort of read the um
you know read what I'm looking at here
all right now you know maybe one other
thing you want to do is change the text
so you can see
up here
you know the Clusters you can see the
text maybe you want to change the color
I think it's in this chart it's this
kind of brownish color I want to have a
black
so we gotta change both sides right
there's a left side and a right side of
the footprint
okay now when it comes then you know you
have this box you want this box to go
away just click on the screen now
for the order flows Trader right now you
can see it down here it's a whole nother
set in here okay so you know things like
exhaustion print okay you can set the
setting to whatever threshold you like
all right if I'm setting it to say
you know default is nine you know if you
want to set it to say five you could
just adjust it right there
um you know other things like for
example thin prints right
I like to use thin prints when I'm
Trading make sure it's enabled except
whatever threshold you want here and
again there's all these things in here
is exhaust and print and balance
reversal ratios slingshot point of
control Market weakness sequencing
uh Market sweeps Prominent Point of
controls zero prints inverse and balance
multiple imbalances
um tails and the thin prints okay so
again there's a lot of tools from the
order flow straighter in here there's
also some tools in
um the regular cluster chart and it's
not about adding every single tool to
your chart all at once thinking hey you
know what I got all these tools I'm
going to use them and I'm going to be a
super Trader no it's about adding what
is useful uh for the market that you're
trading that's going to help you trade
Okay so
let's just uh talk about ratios here for
a second okay so you know if you turn
ratios on right just make sure that the
button here for ratios right is blue
right that means it's on now there is a
difference
um with the
go charting one go charting version of
orif Illustrator and the version that's
available for ninjatrader you're going
to see we've hard coded in the settings
that I use which is uh 27 and 0.69 and
it's only going to appear
on the bars that have a ratio it's going
to appear underneath so you can see the
101 so all these bars that have nothing
above or below
it's just a normal order flow okay and
there are certain ways to use ratios you
know here you can see 46.
um
that is useful right I mean you know
when I first released the overflows
Trader back in 2015 you know this was
one piece of the analysis that was
quickly copied by other software vendors
you know it's funny because I remember
some people were coming up with these
names like the order flow algo or some
other nonsense like that basically it's
just reading what's happening in the
order flow at the bottom of bars of
green up candles or the top of uh red
Down Candles okay and you know I explain
more details in other videos how to use
them
um but really you're just looking for a
ratio that matters right so if you see
the number below that's a bullish ratio
if you see a number above like a red
number above the bar that's a bearish
ratio all right so
um you know one other a couple other
things that you know I want to talk
about on getting your charts set up
now there's there's different ways to
display things like Delta okay so if you
go to your layers right go to your
cluster right close this down so here
cluster right you expand that up State
you know you want to have
Delta okay so you enable this where it
says Delta cumulative Delta
and
Well for now I'll just leave it at that
okay
um you know some people like to see the
volume also okay but I don't think you
really you'd concentrate so much on the
volume
um having it on the bar now I know some
Traders like to have the Delta you know
cumulative Delta Delta numbers you know
right on the bar right because they say
oh I don't take my eyes off I like to
have it on the bottom you know of the
chart I'm just so used to it you know
some people really get offended by
having it on the bottom you know it's
like oh it's trading in the basement and
all you know I just like to keep my bar
areas clean so if you want it on the
bottom like especially if you're coming
over from ninjatrader and some of the
other softwares where it appears on the
bottom what you have to do is go to
see if I find it now
um it's under uh order flow go to order
flow go to Bar statistics
Okay click on it and you can see it's
going to come up right here all you have
to do is just there's this little
divider here just drag it just put your
cursor right right on the top you can
see an up and down arrow and a line in
the middle and just pull it down to the
bottom okay simple so you got volume
Delta Max uh Delta Min Delta cumulative
Delta and
Delta change okay I don't need you know
for me yeah I know some people like to
put the
the day's volume on there
um you know honestly you don't really
need that in my opinion you know the
volume
for the day you know if I'm coming up to
two o'clock you know and it's traded one
million 867 400 contract that means
nothing to me I'm more interested in
what's happening the volume for the bar
is it normal
you know or not I see some light volumes
in here
um you know about you know 1K one and a
half K you know to two and a half k then
I see you know something pick up here
3.6 K okay maybe that that's a bit more
interesting to me than to know that we
went from you know one million 800 600
you know 80
Etc to
added just 3 000 contracts I mean that's
nothing
um so if you don't want to have the
Delta and the cumulative Delta on top of
the bar you can drop it down here on the
bottom I just find it a bit more easier
to read rather than having so much you
know on my chart so what I'm going to do
I'll go back here and turn
this Delta marker came with the marker
off now with go charting just really
quick they have something called Delta
Divergence okay and I just want to put
this on here really quick just to sort
of highlight this to you now this is
different than my order flows Delta
um Divergence you know I
order flow Delta Divergence occurs when
you have a new or equal high with
negative Delta or new equal low with
positive Delta what this Delta
Divergence is for is it will highlight
the bars
that the bar price action and the Delta
differ
okay
so for example
right you have and it'll draw these
lines here through the bar and what it
means is okay so like for example this
bar right here is a green candle with
negative Delta okay it's another green
candle with negative Delta minus 155 a
red candle with positive Delta plus 10 a
red candle with positive Delta now when
you're using a Delta Divergence in this
sense this is more of a bar and Delta
Divergence right because price is going
to One Way Delta is telling you
something else
these are useful reversal points right
so if you're going to use it
don't just use you know you don't say oh
I got a green bar with negative Delta I
gotta get long right really how you want
to trade it is you're going to look at
it for potential
um reversal points okay like you know
here we had this move up get this red
candle with a decent negative Delta 391
I'm sorry positive Delta 391. okay well
why why is this
bar a red candle with positive Delta
what does that mean well it's telling
you that there was some Supply in the
market because what do you have why do
you have positive Delta
on this red candles because early in the
red candle there's a lot of aggressive
buying but there was a strong passive
seller you can see the 1.1 K up here on
the offer
someone offering supply to the market
right just as if I was
um
you know somewhere and we find uh the
opposite case scenario where we had just
sort of come down into the low and then
we start you know like here right we're
coming down into the swing low here and
you got negative Delta on this green
candle why is the Deltas negative right
but price action is positive so what's
that telling you well
there was probably some strong passive
bitters in there to absorb whatever
aggressive selling was taking place as
this Market was going down right then
you see price action starting to reverse
um and we get this nice little rally so
um you know there's there's a way to use
it I I talk about it in some of the
other videos but you know I just want to
get you guys set up in case you know
you're wondering how hey like how do I
add
how do I add the order flows Trader
right to your chart so again just really
quick let's just sort of take you
through it one last time
uh I'll just put this back on a normal
Candlestick right if you come in you got
normal Candlestick and you're trying to
add view order post Trader directly
right and you're clicking on it yeah
there's nothing here I'm clicking on it
again actually if you would go to layers
you'd see it's already added twice
you'll need it twice but what you have
to do first is put the cluster chart on
okay so I'll just take this off so you
can see so it says Candlestick so layers
is the important thing you gotta look
for upper right hand corner layers so go
to chart go to Cluster down here at the
bottom of f right and then just add on
the order flows Trader okay that's it
that's all you got to do it's really
simple you don't need
templates per se all you got it's a
simple click click Right add the cluster
chart
add the order flows Trader and then you
can go in from
the layers you can go into the settings
you could also I believe
right if you click on
the actual footprint right right click
click on settings okay it's going to
give you the settings not for the uh
maybe it's on the bottom not for no this
is just for the footprint okay it's not
but if you want the settings for the
order closed Trader
okay you got to go to the layers all
right in here so
I'm gonna expand it right click on it
and expand it and add whatever you know
you want to look for
um on your chart okay all right everyone
so thanks uh for taking the time to
watch this video again you know the link
for the discounted price on the data is
in the description so
if you don't use that link you're going
to be charged the regular price and
again it's just for the first month it
will renew at the regular price and
again if you want to use a footprint
chart
go charting is a great way to get
started if you want to use my overflows
Trader
um you know for the rest of this month
it's available for you at no extra at no
extra charge so thanks everyone and I'll
see you guys on the next video bye-bye